bienvenue à imitech je suis Stéphane
Dassault le directeur général émi Tech
notre coeur de métier c'est de réaliser
des essais en environnement sur des
équipements essentiellement
électroniques pour valider leur tenue
leur aptitude à évoluer dans
l'environnement pour lequel ils sont
destinés alors quand on parle
d'environnement pour nous ce sont des
organes climatiques des environnements
mécaniques physico-chimiques acoustique
et la première activité sur laquelle
s'est développée la société Mitek c'est
la compatibilité électromagnétique
[Musique]
cette cage est spécifiquement des années
pour réaliser des tests sur moteur
électrique qui fonctionne en vitesse et
en couple qui va être fixé donc sur
notre banc moteur et on va ainsi pouvoir
réaliser toute notre gamme de tests de
compatibilité électromagnétique
[Musique]
depuis cette salle de contrôle Cédric
pilote tout l'environnement de la cage
de Faraday il mesure les champs
électromagnétiques émis ou reçu par le
moteur c'est à dire qu'il doit ne pas
émettre trop de champ électromagnétiques
pour ne pas perturber les autres
équipements qui sont installés sur le
véhicule et il doit eux-mêmes ne pas
être trop susceptible au champ
électromagnétiques qui peuvent être
générés soit par l'environnement du
véhicule ou soit par un environnement
extérieur tel que des lignes hautes
tension ou des chants radars quand on
passe près d'un aéroport tout ceci est
régi par des normes tous les produits
que nous testons à imitesch sont en
phase prototype avant leur mise sur le
marché c'est pour ça que le moteur
aujourd'hui nous ne vous le montrons pas
pour des raisons de confidentialité
évidentes vis-à-vis de nos clients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'automobile le secteur automobile ça
représente 45% du chiffre d'affaires et
mi-tech et toutes les nouvelles
mobilités qui se développent aujourd'hui
toutes les nouvelles architectures de
véhicules que ça soit les véhicules
électriques à batterie les hybrides les
véhicules appuie la combustible sont
autant d'opportunités pour le groupe
MyTech de se développer et de réaliser
des essais et nous avons décidé de faire
un nouvel investissement dans une très
grande cage de Faraday pour non plus
tester uniquement des équipements mais
des véhicules complets
[Musique]
Christophe peux-tu nous expliquer les
spécificités de cette cage de Faraday
par rapport à celle dans laquelle nous
étions tout à l'heure où nous testions
des moteurs électriques là on teste un
système dans son intégralité que ce soit
sur des véhicules comme celui-ci mais ça
peut être également sur les véhicules un
peu plus importants comme des bus des
camions ou des utilitaires on est
capable de tester des véhicules
thermiques des véhicules électriques
hybrides et également des véhicules
hydrogène pourquoi doit-on faire des
essais sur ces véhicules avant de les
mettre sur le marché alors la route
l'électronique est particulièrement
sensible aux ondes électromagnétiques
les ondes électromagnétiques on en a un
peu partout on baigne dans un champ
électromagnétiques donc l'idée c'est de
valider un véhicule pour qu'il soit pas
perturbé lorsqu'il va évoluer sur la
route et on va dans un premier temps de
tester tout ce qui est fonctions
sécuritaires et par la suite toutes les
fonctions accessoires du véhicule
[Musique]
pour travailler dans ce nouveau
laboratoire nous avons créé 10 nouveaux
emplois sur notre site de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux d'ailleurs nous
sommes tout le temps en recherche de
talent si vous êtes technicien si vous
êtes ingénieur n'hésitez pas à consulter
notre site internet et rejoignez-nous